So I think there's one more class
of problems that we didn't
really get a chance get.
There are tons by the way just
to be clear, algorithms and
representation that we
didn't really get into.
A lot of them actually coming out of
big data like k-d trees for example.
But there's a whole class of problems
we didn't really discuss that's
actually quite important.
And that's because it reveals one
of the assumptions that we've had.
I'm going to call them
the assumption of balanced labels.
>> Balanced labels.
>> Yeah, which is related to
cost-sensitive learning and
a variety of other things.
So implicit in a lot of the work that
we talked about was this idea that
if you're a big data set, about half
of them are labeled negative and
about half of them are labeled positive.
>> Sure.
>> Right?
But in practice,
the world doesn't work that way, and
you have to actually
take that into account.
>> So, what would be an example?
>> So, here's my favorite example.
So imagine you have a camera.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Close your eyes.
Now imagine you have a camera, and
let's say that it's in an airport,
like we are now.
And people are going through constantly
and in fact, you're in Atlanta Airport,
which is the world's busiest airport,
and there are cameras constantly taking
pictures of you, and there are, and
we're trying to find terrorists.
So we're taking pictures of people,
and of their faces say, and
maybe what they're wearing, and
we just want to label which ones
are terrorists and which ones aren't.
Well the vast majority of
people are not terrorists,
we hope,
even the ones going through airports.
And so let's say 99% of
the people that come through,
you would label negative, and
less than 1% you would label positive.
Does that make sense as a problem?
>> Yeah, though I'm thinking
about this issue about
most people aren't terrorists.
Like I feel like.
>> That most people are?
>> Are there really any non-terrorists,
or
are we all just terrorists who
just haven't gotten inspired yet?
>> You've met my son.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So
let's say terror is by some
definition ruling to accept.
>> Yeah, yeah.
Let's talk-
>> How about a threat?
A threat-
>> That's where I was going to go.
Yes, forget whether they're terrorists
or not, just In the airport, the airport
terrorists, this person is threatening
to the safety of the airport.
>> And in fact we can back
it up a little bit and
say it was not even terrorists, it's
just someone's that's going to cause
some kind of trouble as
defined by the airports.
So you know we'll get irritated
as they go through the line.
>> Okay, that explains why the last
time that we got together in Atlanta I
was chased by police.
>> You were chased by police.
That's a funny story,
he was literally chased by
the police in the Atlanta airport.
You got outta that one
pretty well I thought.
>> Thanks.
>> Eventually.
>> Yeah.
>> If we're not happy with-
>> [LAUGH]
>> Anyway.
>> So anyway, let's say maybe 3%
of people cause trouble in a day.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Michael.
>> Yeah.
>> And let's say the other 97% don't, so
if you were going to throw this
at a learner, what would happen.
>> Yeah.
>> The best learner is probably the one
that just says.
>> No one will cause trouble.
>> because it could be wrong sometimes,
yeah that's right.
It'll be wrong sometimes,
but very rarely.
>> Yeah, 97% is pretty good,
well that's the problem.
That's what's called
the majority classifier.
>> Yes.
>> And it's a baseline,
which we've talked about a little bit.
And the problem is that when
your algorithm does 97%,
that's actually not very
impressive on the one hand.
But there's another issue which is that.
>> On this date it's not so impressive.
But this other issue which
is the cost of being wrong.
When somebody really is going
to cause trouble is much higher.
So it's actually very important
that you get that 3%,
you can't just treat it as 3%.
So I'm just going to just very
briefly go through this and
then we're going to move on.
There's a bunch of approaches to this.
You could re-weight
the way you do error,
there's all kinds of
clever things you can do.
But there's one that I really like which
is do to Paul Viola and Mike Jones,
it was applied to a vision problem.
It's called cascade learning.
I like this because,
it's a seminal paper.
I like this because it
is rally good work.
And also because Paul Viola
is one of my advisers and
Mike Jones was my office mate
when I was in grad school.
They did all of this while I was sitting
there and didn't put me on their paper.
>> [LAUGH] You think you should be on
the paper just by virtue of the fact you
were there inspiring
them with your presence.
>> My [SOUND] agent
let's them go up by one.
>> Yeah.
>> And that's important.